time for some pft props and deandre
hopkins has an over under of
1124.5 receiving yards and eight and a
half touchdowns he's averaged 128 yards
through seven seasons which are you
going on the over with i you always go
over though you're gonna go over on both
aren't you over 11 24.5 and over eight
and a half touchdowns
this is actually a tough one because i
there
this offense is gonna be explosive we
have still have larry fitzgerald you
have christian kirk like there's going
to be
some competition for balls here so
i'll go you know what i'll go
over yards under touchdowns
wow wow uh
i think definitely over on the yards
because i think murray is going to
realize that there's a reason why
hopkins up was as good as he was in
houston there's a reason he's had
128 yards on average per year i'll agree
with you under the touchdowns too many
weapons in that offense between kenyan
drake between calamari maybe running it
in himself larry fitzgerald christian
kirk andy isabella i think that uh i
think that that is uh a legitimate
concern all right ravens over under 11
and a half wins the folks at william
hill said that 75 of the betting is
coming in on the under for the ravens
even though they were 14-2 last year
where are you on the ravens win total
whoo you know i
i would definitely under under regular
circumstances take the under just
because i'm a big believer in you know
regression and teams always getting that
you know big bull's-eye where
hey last year they kind of surprised a
few teams for maybe not surprising that
they were good but surprising how good
they were
the only reason i'm gonna go over mike
is
the defense of lamar jackson trying to
figure out how to defend him
you know what doesn't help
doing all your defensive installs on
zoom you know what doesn't help not
being able to you know have a full
training camp maybe they will have full
training camp but all these things add
up and i think looking at teams that
have the same quarterback and the same
coach and the same offense
from last year they will always have a
leg up going into this season versus the
teams with new quarterback new coach new
offense whatever it may be one pick one
of the three so i'm going to take over
on the baltimore ravens wins
yeah you know that's an actually good
point when when we see a guy don't be
surprised
don't be surprised
it is a little bit of a surprise but but
we see defensive coordinators obsess
over
coming up with a way to stop it i
remember when the read option was a big
deal and how do we stop it and and yeah
you have a chance to to sit in meeting
rooms together and really have
meaningful discussions and take it out
to the practice field and try different
things and and it's harder to
collaborate now than than it is in a
normal year so yeah i'm going to agree
with you that peop that lamar jackson is
still going to have a huge gap between
himself and everyone else i'll go over
on 11 and a half wins it doesn't mean
they're gonna be 14 and two but i think
they'll at least be 12 and four rams
also under eight and a half wins is the
primary bet that william hill is seeing
83 percent of the people are taking
under eight and a half where are you on
the rams over under eight and a half
wins
i'll go over with this one um i'm a
believer in sean mcvay i just think that
you know
just like you would bet against a team
that over achieves one year and then and
then regresses i think the rams
underachieved last year and they had
that super bowl hangover last year which
definitely plays a factor so i will take
the over i think they're a nine or a 10
win team just because sean mcphaie is
that good like sean mcvay will find a
way i think you'll see
uh somewhere down the line you know in
20 30 years sean mcvay have a similar
uh not he's not gonna win six lombardi's
like bill belichick but a similar sense
of
doesn't really matter who's on the
roster he will always put a competitive
team out there and they will always be
at worst around 500.
this is the test this year they've done
some bad contracts they've made some bad
business decisions they don't have todd
gurley they traded away brandon cooks
they have to figure out what they're
going to do with jalen ramsey they're
going to pay him and they're not going
to pay him i feel like this is a
crossroads year for the rams and if they
are good it's going to be because of
mcveigh i still don't believe in jared
goff if he doesn't have todd gurley with
him at a high level of performance i
just don't think it's going to work i'm
going to go under especially in that
division with the cardinals of the
seahawks and the 49ers playing them
twice per year all right how about this
one from the coach of the year props
there are four mats who are plus 3 000
meaning you bet 100 and they become
coach of the year you win three thousand
bucks matlab floor of the packers matt
neggie of the bears matt patricia of the
lions matt rule of the panthers which of
those mats would you take as a long shot
at plus 3000 to be coach of the year
all right i'm biased uh
obviously to matt nagy and i actually
think that that would be the most
compelling case wouldn't you say that
the that in terms of what what are you
gonna get to make be coach the year you
have to get to the playoffs right and to
be coaches you really have to get to the
playoffs after a year you didn't make
the playoffs so cross the floor out
there rule matt rule while i think he's
going to be a good coach the nfl that
team has a full rebuild that's going on
right now
and matt patricia who would you take the
lions of the bears to get to the
playoffs this next year
well and here's the thing and nagi was
the coach of the year in 2018 and the
reason he was coaching the year in 2018
is his team exceeded the generally
accepted expectations for that team by
the biggest margin so i think to best
position this we have to gauge what are
the expectations for each team and i
agree with you on the floor even though
there's kind of a sense that they may be
on the front end of some dysfunction if
they make it to the playoffs everybody's
gonna say yeah they were supposed to
make playoffs they have aaron rodgers
it's going to be hard for matt lafleur
unless they go like 16-0 or 15-1 i think
it comes down to patricia or rule
because those are the two teams with the
lowest expectations and if the panthers
go nine and seven and become the seventh
seed in the nfc hey look at what matt
rule did first year as an nfl coach he
had he had a cup of coffee with the
giants as an assistant offensive line
coach he came in with no offseason
program give it to matt roll so i think
it comes down to patricia a rule and it
won't surprise me if it's matt rule so i
i just don't
i don't see them winning that enough
games and also just to just to throw it
out there mike uh the
coach of the year just looking through
it always wins double-digit games the
only time it didn't happen was when
bruce arians won it filling in for chuck
pagano with nine and three record in uh
2012 so nine and seven won't get it get
it for you jimmy johnson was the last
guy who actually won it
1990 with tell me the record the dallas
cowboys jimmy johnson won coach of the
year with this record mike
i don't know nine and seven eight and
eight seven and nine seven seven nine
wow
yeah so
you're looking at the history you have
to win double digit games to win coach
of the year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports